Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the Try Not To Cringe Challenge!
Now- thankfully I'm not sick so(yeah)
sorry to everybody that wanted a sick trifecta of cringing goodness
but this time around-
I'm going into this fully prepared(ok then)
and medicinally not suppressed so this time
I should be (chuckle) fully exposed to all the glory that is the cringe.
And uh, thankfully I'll be staying away from all the E3 stuff-
I KNOW IT'S BAD! I'm (laugh) fully aware that this E3 was bad
but I feel like everyone else already covered that so I'm
just gonna-
I'm gonna sh-
WE'RE GONNA SCOOT ON BY THAT
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO WIN WHEN YOU'RE GOING AT THE E3 STUFF SO I'M JUST GONNA MOVE RIGHT ON.
Maybe a little bit..yeah- LET ME T- LET M- MAYBE OOONE.
Jesse: "What up guys? My name is Jesse Wellens and I am a YouTube creator so I am here-"
"-to...talk about...Need For Speed...um..."
(awkward silence)
Jesse: "..Payback!(random guy shouts at the background) Uh if you guys didn't know- Need For Speed Payback..."
(awkward silence the sequel)
Jesse: "...I'm- but- um-... ( awkward chuckle)"
(awkward chuckle replays but now it's slow because comedy and tries to smile like chucky)
Oh no Jesse no
Jesse: "Yeah, is great game!"
"BUT ALRIGHT!-"(shows hands becouse they are smexy af)
"All set aside I'm a YouTube creator- Need For Speed Payback is coming out-"(On November 17th)
"I got my boy Marcus executive producer here. He is the producer of the game-"
"thank you Nick for having me." *cue awkward handshake to rejected hug*
("Thank you, Nick-" but slower because comedy the sequel)
Marcus: "Hey man, Jesse (distorted um)- obviously we're really excited to tell everyone about Need For Speed Payback here today-"
AAAAH
NOOO I FEEL SO BA-
( markimoo laughter)
-D (marki laughter continues)
OH NO- NO I CAN'T
I just- (chuckle) I feel bad cuz in any scenario that
could be me!
(chuckle) If I- if I was trying to do a presentation for something
I know I would fuck it up REEEAAL BAAAD
and it would be so much worse
-heck half my videos are more cringy than this (yeah probably) so I think we can be fine
and give him a little bit of a break. So I'm gonna
(chuckle) we're just- THE- THE CHALLENGE HASN'T STARTED YET
EVERYBODY HOLD ON TO YOUR HORSES (I don't have one, Mark) THE CHALLENGE IS NOT UNDER WAY
(laugh) IT HASN'T STARTED
(chuckle) WE'RE FINE
So- as with most of these Try Not To Cringe Challens (he meant challenges)
they're practically impossible
but I will try to look at this with a wall of impassive (accidentally hits mic)
emotionless (continuously hits mic) nature-
YOU UNDERSTAND IT (slaps the poor mic repeatedly) YOU PIECE OF FRIKIN' SHIT
(Rest in  Pepperonis mic)
FUCK YOOU (Mark why? You okay?)
Alright so you know the rules if you cringe you- die(uh oh)
apparently or something like that...
Reporter: Ok well uh, which one of the other players"
"on the other team, would you say are your biggest...competition...in this game?"(gives a deadly look)
"HNS": "No one biiiitch
(laughter and cheering in the background) (mark grimaces)
Reporter: "Well you HAVE lost three matches in a row."
(mark holding in his laughter) Reporter: So that kinda makes you the underdogs in this game, right?
"HNS": "Yeah we were only like...warming up until now...so yeah...this is the... the day we... show out potential"
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA(wtf mark)
Who you get off (tf are you saying) calling people a biiiiiiitch-that's right biiiitch!
Get rekt- beeeeeehhhh! (bitch)
This one just says the second hand embarrassment is strong in this one
oh no
(chuckle)
Le- Let's-
Everyone pull up your cringe checklist-
Classroom? (laugh) Yup! Colored shirts? Yup!
(laugh) Vertical video? I got a feeling about this one.
(oh no they're singing)
My name's Kristine! (Yeah?) I love karaoke! (Yeah) And that's just me! (Rolecall)
Shabooya, sha- sha- shabooya, rolecall!
My name is Chelsea! (Yeah?) I love the  alini(?), black and blue, cuz I'm an allumni!
(Rolecall!) Shabooya, sha- sha- shabooya, rolecall!
My name is Bree! (Yeah?) Loves food and travel, (yeah?) And I love baseball, (yeah?) Go Cardinals!
Shabooya, sha- sha- shabooya, role- I think I'm good, (yeah?) Give me a chance!
DID YOU JUST DAB? (laughter)
Hey waitt-
DID YOU JUST DAB?(he dabbed on them haterz)
cuz that's not okaaay
-I mean it's okay I do it all the time but I
do it ironically (laughs) like half the time! (laughter) I'm no better than these people
I'm no BETTER!
it was- like- (laughs) it's th- THE PROBLEM WITH THESE
ALWAYS IS THEY DON'T FULLY COMMIT- LIKE YOU (LAUGHS) HAVE TO FULLY COMMIT
AND EVEN THEN IT'S NO BETTER
CUZ I MEAN THE...THE- THE-it reminds me of the uh (Come on Mark you can say them words)
person who sang the syllabus
oooh man it was so good
oh man- BUT I CAN'T FAULT THESE PEOPLE I CAAAAN'T I CAN'T FAULT THEM THEY'RE SO LOVABLE
ANd adorable..<3 (like you)
It says "guy uses toy boats to confess his love to a crush pain starts around 1:35"
Scott: "Hey Rachel"
Rachel: "Hey Scott"
Scott: "I brought to up here for a reason."
Rachel: "Okaaay..?"
Scott: I'm not sure if you can see this but these are lil'...
"toy boats."
"Let's call this a "Friendship"...kay?"
"And this is a"Friendship" too, right?
"We've been- y'know like...sailing these lil' friendships y'know for a while and stuff like that"
"like a YEAR, right? But there's another boat that's in the harbor."
(I feel bad for him already)
"You're ready for this? Huh?" Rachel: I don't know.." Scott: Huh?
(mark chuckles)
Scott: "This boat..."
"Is called..."
"a "relationship" you see that?" Scott: Here's the thing"- (laughter) OH SHE'S NOT AMUSED
Scott: "I think there's a way to go from a friendship to a relationship and in order to get to the relationship"
"we have to share things-  you ready for this?"
(oh buddy look at her face)
SHE'S NOT READY
Scott: "To bridge the gap between this and this -hold yours up"
"You see this? DO YOU SEE THIS?
"Ok it says 'Cher'...there's a Cher concert coming up"
(markimoo grunts)
Scott: "And what I attempted to do not so smoothly was bring you up here and ask you if you'll go with me"(mark is dying)
"to the Cher concert."
(awkward silence)
Scott: "I'm listening."
(song plays in the background while awkward silence endures) (but like, why film in a dark car? why film or do this at all?)
Rachel: "I just wanna let you know right now I- I think of you as just a friend..."
"Scott, I think you're a great guy"
"But..."
(silence) (SCOTT STOP SMILING LIKE THAT, SHE'S NOT INTERESTED)
Is it short, fat, white and desperate in here? Or is it just me? (Scott why?)
Scott: "What the heck- I'm just like feeling so awkward."
Rachel: "I'm-I'm sorry Scott."
Scott: "It's okay we're still friends."
(exhales) Alright- y'know what I'm out I'm out of that one I'm out of that one I'm out-
I'm out of that one yes (I think he's broken) I'm out of that one that is not going to stay here
NO.
I like- I lo- The best part of that was when
the awkward silence was happening and then they had a cut. So that means there was even more
awkward silence that they had to cut out of that!
Weird slapping noises
Man: "BUT YOU CAN'T DO IT."
"BOI YOU CAN'T DO THIS ON CONCRETE"(jesus christ that was a legit talent right there)
Dude in the background: "OH SHIT"
Did he die? (I'm sad now)
This is "Mexican Andy Picks Up Girls With Ice Poseidon".
And ANYBODY WITH THE NAME- with the name Ice Poseidon has GOT to be at the top of his game.
Like the absolute pinnacle of his pickup game and I can't wait to see what this is
Mexican Andy: "Hey"
Mexican Andy: "Excuse me? Excuse me"
Ice Poseidon: "He's talking to you."
Girl 1: "Oh I did not know that...sorry!" Girl 2: "Okay...SO WHAT?" Girl 1: "Is that okay?"
Mexican Andy: "What's going on?"
Girl 2: "What do you mean?"
Mexican Andy: "You're getting- you got in trouble or something or what?"
Girl 2: "Uuuh" Girl 1: "I dunno...why would you assume that?"
Mexican Andy: "Uh I don't know it looks like you two are looking at the uh y'know..."
Girl 1: "We're waiting on friends." Girl 2: "Yeah." Mexican Andy: "Oh ok."
Girl 1: "Have a good night." Mexican Andy: You too.
Ice Poseidon: "LADIES! (stutters) What- What's going on?" Girls: "We're (inaudible)"
I'm  gues- (chuckle) OH MAN I'M GUESSING THAT'S ICE POSEIDON (laughs) the tall guy has gotta be Ice Poseidon
(laughter)
(giggle) there's no one that smooth on this Earth ooh my god
(imitating girl 1) Have a nice day
This one just says "you have a most interesting face"?? (confusiplier)
Guy: "Are you in line?"
Girl: "No- the line is that way! Outside." Guy: "Oh it's outside?"
Guy: Are you from Czech Republic?
Girl: "No."
Guy: "You look very interesting."
Girl: (giggle) "Ok,thank you?"
Guy: "You have a most interesting face."
Girl:In whole London
(awkwardiplier)
OH JUST LEAVE JUST LEAVE THERE YOU GO JUST LEAVE
OH MY GOD (chuckle)
What did that guy have a go-pro strapped to his fucking face and then
and then he just- the awkward (stutter) ok bye!(wtf mark)
God the  street flirting videos are just the goddamn worst (agreed) UGH
This one says "high-five denied".
Girl: (laughs)
(Poor guy waiting for a high-five)Mark:Oh no!
(laughs)
("How Could This Happen To Me" by Simple Plan starts playing"
(mark laughs)
(markilaughter endures)
oh no oh no I've been there I've been there- believe it or not I've been there!
I think I've told this story before actually
I have literally been in that exact scenario because I-
oh my- how long is that gonna go for oh my god hey woah it's alright I'm not gonna give you a high-five
I'm not gonna give you a face-five either please (light laugh) back off hey ok it's alright.(zooming in face)
But I've been- I've been there before I have actually been there
(laughs) I was in English class in high school and there was this other- this guy I can't remember the name of
and this girl named Sammy (of course you remember the girl's name) and we were in a group
y'know all the teacher-parents getting together in a group so we're together and I can't remember what we were working on
but I was trying to be (laughs) motivational (awe cute) and I
I was like "We can do this! We're gonna do great!"
"High-five!" and the guy he gave me a high-five but then when I- when I went to Sammy
(laughs)
I remember this very clearly
she just slowly turns to me and says
"No."
(markigiggles) and then I had to slowly put my hand  down (oh poor teen markimoo)
and then I didn't say anything
for the rest of the class
and I don't think I said a word in like (laughs)- all the rest of the entire course.
ooh man
I think I lost I think it's safe to say that I lost that
challenge which is obvious because I
I don't think there's any way to win that!
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE!
How could you?!
And I'm like HALF AS CRINGEY AS THOSE GUYS EVER WOULD BE!
But anyway that's all the time I have for the Try Not To Cringe Challenge.
How did you guys do
let me know down in the comments below
if any of you managed to not cringe at that
HOLY (giggle) CRAP
you have a black stone for a soul and I like it! (;
Not really but it's- it's you.
So thank you everybody so much
for watching if you wanna see more of this cringeable
stuff let me know down in the comments
and if you got your own favorite things to cringe at
lemme (smash) know down there as well.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
I will see YOU
in the next video!
Buh-Bye! :D(bai mark)